good morning believe nation today's
message is keep going over to you Robin
Williams awake will he be go just keep
going find that thing you love because
it's tough work and my father gave me
this advice when I said I wanted to be
an actor he said have a backup
profession like welding but I think if
you can find that thing that really
gives you joy that'll be it because up
for me it's always been comedy and stand
up and enacting to because of exploring
behavior but it's tough work but it's NS
if you can get it even better good luck
this message for me is that the core of
entrepreneurship I think for me the two
key things that all successful
entrepreneurs have is one they had the
courage to get started into the kept
going no matter how hard it was to help
how many obstacles got put in their path
and learning how many little men stood
in their way they got started and they
kept going and a lot of people think is
about how in the type a extroverted
personality your boat having the stead
of capital about going to the right
school or having the right connections
or having the right parents doesn't
matter it's not about any of those
Saints there's been tons of people who
started with less resources than what
you currently have today and became
mega-successful and tons of people who
are given everything had everything
handed to them had all the opportunities
and connections and resources and fail
it doesn't matter where you're starting
from what matters is you have the
courage to get started and you keep
going no matter what so the question day
today is I'm curious when was the
hardest time you had to keep going what
was the hardest moment in your life
where you wanted to quit or did quit
share it below I think it could inspire
the people who are watching well and
hopefully by you kind of overcoming that
it'll give you the courage to go through
the next wall that comes at you so share
it below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also wanted to give a quick
shadow to Carlos and Marla from truth
speaks coaching thank you guys so much
for ordering my book it means a lot to
me for those of you guys who want to
shout out in a future video your change
at it make sure you pick up a copy of
the book and then email in your receipts
so that we can keep track thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
you to believe or whatever your one word
is and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events peso oh
wait espresso give me go